Anthony albanesi is the first Australian
prime minister to visit China since 2016
his 4-day trip is aimed at easing years
of diplomatic strain between the two
countries albanesi was a guest of honor
at China's import export export that's
opened in Shanghai it is in all our
interest to have a relationship where
there is dialogue and cooperation
tension were spiked in 2018 when the
previous Australian government banned
Chinese Telecom giant Huawei from its 5G
Network and for an investigation into
the origins of the co 19 pandemic in
2020 Beijing responded by imposing a
diplomatic freeze and trade curbs on
Australian Imports and the Democratic
process elected in 2022 albanesi has
sought to improve ties with cra's
biggest trading partner in recent months
Beijing has removed tariffs on wheat and
barley my mom and released Australian
journalist Chong L after 3 years of
detention on spying charges but
significant differences remain Australia
continues to deepen its relationship
with the United States and Australia
continues to have a really high threat
perception when it comes to the Chinese
government and its activities on the
world
stage China has criticized Australia's
plan to purchase nuclear powered
submarines from the US and its joining
of the so-called quad security pact that
also includes India and Japan Beijing
hopes repairing ties with Australia will
prevent it from following Washington's
tough toward China approach too closely
it's also expected to push for canas
support in signing up to the cptpp trade
pact for countries linked by the Pacific
Ocean Anthony albanesi is scheduled to
travel to Beijing and meet Chinese
president seden ping on Monday Katrina U
aler
Beijing make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer